I want to pull up this story from the
Daily Mail Bruce Willis sells rights to
permit deep fake digital twin of himself
to be created for use on screen allowing
him to come out of retirement after
Aphasia diagnosis no he's not coming out
of retirement this is just the beginning
of what what should we call this we need
an era the Deep fake area Darkly area
Scanner Darkly earth look we were just
talking about how they you're not going
to know what's real yeah they're they'll
deep fake a video of you know Trump or
something and then people just gonna
believe it I was on Rogan's show uh it
was I think it was last year and he
asked me like are you worried about the
Deep fake stuff and I was like nah I
don't I don't I'm not worried about that
because
you know people you're they're gonna
know where Trump is they're gonna know
where you know whoever the president is
they're going to know where they're at
when they're speaking now that I'm
looking at it and I think I deeply
underestimated the abilities of deep
fake technology and this is just the
beginning a video will go viral and it
will be of President you know one two
three whoever and they'll say something
that won't sound too crazy but will be
worrying they'll say something like this
this is what you need to watch out for
you'll get a video of a president saying
we need to focus on our tax reduction
plan
and all they'll do is change reduction
to uh to you know incremental something
very simple to shift support away from
the person they'll say something like it
is true we're offering a one percent
income tax reduction and then they take
that video and deep fake increase and
then they send that out it goes viral
this is when I hear them say stuff like
you know we have to be concerned about
missing disinformation hey they're not
wrong that just send the order and being
like people will use misinformation I'm
like they will the problem is it's
primarily been coming from government
and major corporations so my fear is not
the random dude in his living room who
somehow gets access to a deep fake
generator or like a good one because
people can actually get these consumer
grade ones my concern is government or
military grade technology that can
generate deep fakes and then one day
you're an anti-war activist you're
you're saying Julian Assange and then
all of a sudden a video gets leaked
which is indistinguishable from from any
other normal video of you saying
something believable but reputation
damaging and you come out and say that's
a deep fake and people are going to be
like oh get Audi a conspiracy theorists
and then the media can run the video and
when you threaten a sue they'll say but
your honor we have a video of him saying
it and the judge's going to be like can
you prove it's fake and they're gonna go
how do you prove it's fake it's a deep
fake and they're like either prove it's
a deep fake or it stands that's the
world we're entering and you know what I
gotta tell you we're there already we
are there now this story about Bruce
Willis this is entertainment I've heard
that people that government
organizations will like put files on
people's computer and then go get their
you oh you got child porn on your
computer
do you have a deep fakes too they call
as government mean to control the mind I
mean mint is like meant is meant is mind
governed the the root of the word is to
direct or control it's a Rome it's a
Latin term it's just mind control I mean
that's the essence of government is
controlling people's thoughts well and
and it must be noted that the that
Jefferson the quote on the inside of the
Jefferson memorials I declare Eternal
hostility against any form of tyranny
over the mind of man and that they were
wanting to tear it down in 2020.
interesting that's all you know wow man
we also have to understand that this
technology also is developing at such a
very fast rate this is what's public
what is not public what don't we know
about and personally from my own
speculations and my own kind of thinking
about this if you could deep fake actors
and and certain videos you could
probably deep fake individuals you could
probably deep fake uh influencers you
could probably deep fake entire social
media accounts to pretend to be somebody
pushing an agenda that of course is
going to be making videos is going to
having you know the Selfies is going to
be of course broadcasting about
everything but everything's going to be
user computer AI generated to push a
certain idea to emotionally manipulate
you in a certain way that benefits a
multinational corporation or a private
entity in interest that of course
haven't in that that want to manipulate
you for their own personal causes who's
going to be doing that very powerful
people the Corp the the billionaires the
multinational corporate versions the
government the secret societies the
intelligence agencies all of the people
now saying hey you have increased
speeches bad we need to control all of
it which is an absurd idea and and and
what Ian is saying is is not too far
away from the reality it is trauma-based
mind control that a lot of people are
going through are unaware of it and this
is one of the main ways that they they
use to control people is with emotions
and now ai generated content creators I
think that's something that we should be
looking out for Ian is 100 correct meant
the uh that's the suffix comes from the
Latin Mente meaning mind yeah mental and
then govern is to steer drive or control
that's not doesn't mean that's the
current government of the day who's the
current government of the day Google
alphabet they're controlling what we see
here and think I mean not directly but
indirectly I think directly I mean
you can opt in but not really I mean go
go go down the street I was at a water
park just just not too long ago in the
middle of Oklahoma and I went up and I
was like hey I need some quarters they
were like we're a cashless we don't
accept cash
you know what I mean and in order to do
that then okay well I've got a phone I
don't have my card you know maybe it's
in the locker or whatever you have to
opt in to the technology to be a part of
society now so I I I think it's
absolutely direct and it's pervasive and
it's becoming more and more pervasive in
not just the AI way or not just the Deep
fake way but in the everyday I I've got
to feed my family you know go to school
kind of way that everyone deals with and
that's that's the real danger of this is
that it's it's a part of everyday life
so it's actually a Greek before uh Latin
uh kuberman and goober mare the the
Greek word kubernet this is what Google
says for etymology it was to steer and
then in Latin became guber mare which
meant to steer and Rule which led to old
French governor which was probably just
pronounced govern and then they added
meant of the mind so to steer and
control the Mind fascinating there you
go you learn you you what is it you
learn something yeah no no no more you
know the military and the military
certainly is used to control your mind
because it's the threat of force that
gets you to pay your taxes and things
like that government
um but it's not that's not really the
man it's like a usurpation of global
governance happened in the last 20 years
and I'm you know we're waking up to it
the liberal International economy my
friend yes it was stripped by corporate
by alphabet like they without us
realizing it they just took control of
the narrative you guys have it what do
you got to do with it man it's amorphous
you know
there's a point where AOL was the
dominant digital Force but it wasn't
that powerful Because the Internet
wasn't that powerful and then AOL still
exists but I mean who talks about them
Yahoo still exists but come on alphabet
is insane and it's like 11 companies or
something yeah it's a black rock it's
the corporation yeah it's like just
welcome to the Sci-Fi dystopia where the
corporation and they're like yeah that's
why they called it alphabet they're
making fun of like uh NBC and CBS and
abs they're like yeah CIA FBI they're
like we're all of them man we are the
alphabet yeah that's wow that's creepy
that's one form of government is
alphabet but you have to wonder if
that's true and they're as powerful as
we as as many fear why would they allow
this show
is it because there's nothing we can do
to stop it well maybe but I think it's
also that inadvertently we hit points
all of us do in the because we actually
think we hit points that they like at
certain points and they think okay well
at this point we're going to allow it up
to this point because they're still
giving us what we want even though we
don't like most of what they're saying
and because we're free thinking people
right but at a certain point you get to
an Alex Jones or you get to a you know
uh another person like that or even
James Lindsay being taken off Twitter
the moment you hit it the too much they
take you down you know I'm telling you
you gotta get chickens you'd really
understand this right so we have I think
30 chickens outside and they're all
doing their chicken thing and it's fine
but we had a couple a couple roosters in
there and then when they start acting up
they get removed and sent to cocktown
the penal colony where all the rooster
boys
yeah because they're always fighting
fascinating they're always fighting and
so so the point is
I don't care what the chickens do at all
they can fight eat bang whatever but
when they step too far with it they get
removed so my view is maybe a show like
this they view similarly like hey yeah
they're all in their Coop doing their
stupid thing it's not it doesn't matter
to us we don't care but Alex Jones on
the other hand he was that loud
obnoxious rooster that wouldn't stop
screaming right and finally they were
like okay now now this rooster is
causing me problem I'm having a meeting
and it's screaming and squawking and
it's and now my the guy that said I'm
trying to sell to he leaves so say okay
we're taking them out and we're putting
them in the penal colony right once you
you will know when you've stepped out of
line well and and that has happened even
to a smaller you know I've got 20 20 000
Twitter followers but I'm working with a
with a group a guy named Alvin Louis of
Courage is a habit it's a great name
great organization to go look for it but
um he uh we we just under uncovered this
this kind of scandalous videos uh from
aska which is the American School
American School Counselors Association
and within what is it 17 hours we all
both of us got uh banned from Twitter
from YouTube from from Amazon and from
Google and it was like we're nobody you
know I mean you you guys have hundreds
of thousands of views but we hit
something and then the next day the next
day
a video comes from the Federal
Department of Education just praising
school counselors it was amazing I'd
never seen anything like it and the
censorship targets the smaller accounts
because they don't make a ripple when
they're banned that's true so they're
pulling out you know look you get a big
thick hair and You Yank it out of
someone's head it hurts but you got a
little peach fuzz here you can pop them
up people don't feel anything that's
basically what this is they know that if
they ban bigger channels it creates
Ripples and it amplifies at least
temporarily and may you know what it's
saying you got a roaches step on it the
eggs go flying everywhere or something
like that that's what they want to avoid
so they go for the smaller they they're
going for the Grassroots they're cutting
the roots at the core to eliminate the
support if you're banned from YouTube or
Twitter as a small follower then it's a
lot harder for you to follow along
interact with and support the person who
is speaking that's that's Twitter
strategy well and that's it's happening
on YouTube too I mean I'm right now I am
more Shadow banned on Twitter than I've
ever been uh and and it's because of the
fight that we're having in Oklahoma
about these these hospitals in the trans
issue and it just got a little too close
to home and it's amazing to me to see it
because I just thought oh I'm small you
know I I've got a decent following for
the area but I'm small but you're right
they come after you because if they get
us you know and you have no Grassroots
you all can talk all you want in in
these bigger platforms but it's it's the
Grassroots that really makes the the
bottom-up change and so I don't know I
don't know what we do about that we we
have to start doing something well we
need to please ourselves from the bottom
up I think the corporation alphabet's
got it's balancing the heaviest Hammer
ever noticed by Humanity essentially
like intellectual hammer and and they
have 12 some of these commoner we have
some of their companies Calico human
health company over overcome aging
Capital G's private Equity Deep Mind
does artificial intelligence Google
Google does internet services Google
fibers its own company uh GV is a
venture capital company intrinsic does
robotic software isomorphic Labs does
drug Discovery verily is a human health
company uh waymo is autonomous driving
Wing does drone based delivery and X
development is research in Dev for
moonshot they're taking us to space
these Technologies in the hands of a
private company are very very dangerous
if the proprietary code is alternative
open sourcing the code so that we at
least know how to counteract drones when
they mount machine guns on them and
start hacking them and flying them over
you know uh cities and and suburbs and
but like in a detrimental way that's
negative or illegal or a moral and
ethical uh what do you mean is anything
that could happen I mean you've seen
Terminator two the guy didn't know he
was building the Terminator while he was
building it it's propriety if when this
when you guys you're listening right now
the owners you guys said alphabet when
you sell the company the next guy to get
to that code has control of the world
also a lot of people who worked on the
nuclear bomb didn't know that they were
working on the nuclear bomb a lot of the
scientists also regretted it there's
also a lot of cases of the scientists
who worked on it committing suicide
because of the guilt that they felt
building this but but to go along with
the point that started this conversation
if if resistance resistance was futile
they wouldn't need to censor us and they
are censoring us and there are a lot of
underhanded things that we still don't
even know about that happen on YouTube
on Twitter on Google on Facebook on on
MailChimp almost everywhere online there
are small underhanded things happening
that are not as blatant that are not as
big as censorship and I think what we're
seeing here is is kind of like the
boiling of the Frog analogy slowly and
surely they're pushing for this but they
know that they can't move too quickly
because their whole agenda and their
whole game will be uncovered because
it's essentially the truth that will
expose it all and that's what they're
afraid of it sous-vide is that what it's
called yeah the eggs no it's the the
vacuum slow cooking warm water oh yes I
see the eggs version oh okay Starbucks
yeah yeah yeah yeah you guys know what
that is yeah like you vacuum seal
sous-vide you vacuum seal the meat and
then you put it in the warm water for
like 20 hours and then it makes it like
really tender or whatever so that's
what's happening that's what's happening
we're not even boiling let me tell you
guys a story I was once playing World of
Warcraft on my laptop and I had it on my
lap This was 18. oh my oh man this got
to be how old was I was 20. I know where
this is going
where's it going oh it's about singing
leg hairs the hairs frying your eggs
yeah tell me more so I'm sitting Indian
style so it's being held up by my thighs
on my left and my right I'm sitting in
bed and um you know I'm just applying my
laptop got really hot
when I took the laptop off
my left leg itched and I scratched it
and pulled skin right off the computer
was hot but only slowly and it burned me
blistered and I didn't notice because it
happened so slowly when I put the laptop
on my on when I was sitting with my
laptop it was cold after playing for a
couple hours it was really really hot
and constantly on my skin and I didn't
feel any pain and it was a small blister
that I ended up I itched and pulled it
right off well and part of that was too
your mind was so focused on something
else so it just removed all the
sensation from the other parts of your
body and all the blood rushing to that
that neuro you know the the the dopamine
and stuff you're getting from the game
it it removes feeling from the rest of
your body and it fries your balls and
many doctors are saying that it actually
has a very bad impact on on male sperm
sperm counts so when people are heavily
focused on energy helps on their
desensitized yeah they become
desensitized because when you're focused
on something that isn't real
and it makes you know it makes the it
makes the real less real Faraday cage
underwear yeah yes oh that's a good idea
now with all the with all the you know
Warfare against the balls
Faraday cage uh fanny pack put my phone
in there when I walk around yeah it
doesn't irradiate my nuts I have a
faraday cage like pouch that my dad sent
me because he's like you're paranoid too
here's a Verity cage for your phone I
should get one of these
in there yeah we should call the company
and say can you make underwear they
should sponsor my money and we can make
the underwear a little clothing in
general it doesn't work because
um it has to be close so I'll give you
an example the tin foil hat thing
actually has the inverse effect it
amplifies yeah because the signals can
still enter from underneath through your
body now water does block a lot of this
stuff you need a one-way mirror you need
a full Faraday suit so it can block
every part so if you want to walk around
you ever see those faradays they're
really cool yeah if you want to walk
around in that I guess or when it can
get out but it can't get in so it'll
sneak in the corners and then can get
work its way back out we should just
build Outlook we should build a triple
layer Faraday cage just to do it and
film it and like we should do one big
one a small one and then inside the so
there's there's a big one you can walk
in then another one inside that and then
there's a box and so we can see at what
point the cell phone stops we were
actually planning on building that where
do you want to do it you understand okay
you think we should start construction
soon let's do it before it's too cold
yeah we could probably whip that up
pretty quick and then I mean in in
reality we probably want to put it
indoors yeah for sure because now we
could store stuff in it yeah that'd be
cool yeah basically
so the old prepper trick is to is to put
a microwave like in deep storage and put
a phone in a laptop in it but it's like
unplugged obviously you know I don't
think that freeing telling alphabet
corporate execs to free the code is is
sensical enough I know you guys think
like come on Ian that's like that's just
such a hitting it with a sledgehammer I
know you can't just give it give it all
away it's not but at some point I mean
if you are trying to hold on to this
power it's gonna obliterate your hand
and then it's gonna consume us like we
can't no no sector group of us can do
this alone
only only beings of extraordinary
strength could wheel touch power I mean
if if somebody were to hold this then
powerful bursts of purple energy light
would emit from their hand and then they
would scream and explode and it would
just be damaged but a true defense a
group of people that are close and
friends could hold each other's hands
and temporarily contain that power just
enough to defeat Ronan oh I'm gonna
start doing a meditation a group
meditation if you guys want to join me
at 2 p.m tomorrow I'll be meditating
I'll be doing it for at least five
minutes and if you want to jump in right
at 2 p.m Eastern Standard Time I think
that the power of good needs to organize
what are you going to focus on nothing
empty mind
and let it happen and you can meditate
there are some very interesting studies
about big meditation groups focusing on
one thing and helping
um actually bring those things forward
well that's the scientific case for
prayer yes you know what I mean the the
prayer meditation
when you focus you know and you can have
whatever focus on your intentions yeah
yeah or just focus towards a result but
if you do it from the the standpoint of
God or or wherever you do it it
obviously hasn't it's my backfire by
giving the idea look at his eyes
I got it we want to make sure that
everybody's listening who does do the
group meditation with Ian that they have
the intention of something good and
Noble yeah so I think tomorrow at 2PM
when everyone begins to meditate they
should all focus on aliens coming to
Earth no no no no no no no no no no no
but hold on you're gonna look at us
they're like Kamala Harris Joe Biden are
your leaders of the Free World we're
taking it yeah get it out get it out of
here make sure you denote time zone yeah
it's a joke on all of life in the
universe we gotta get rid of it focus on
whatever you want I trust you we I think
it's going to work itself out as long as
we're all working on this thing no no no
no don't listen to him everyone focus on
Ian getting ripped yeah there you go
don't make me get ripped and finally
working out okay I'm getting ripped I'm
gonna start working out and right after
the meditation so inspired something
just overtakes Ian's body yeah and he
gets up he's like what's happening I'm
walking to the gym no I'm picking up the
weights we tried this in 2007 on
stickem.com but the software wasn't good
enough to get more than like 15 of us in
a chat room and the software crashed
when we had like 40 or 80 people and
they're trying to meditate I don't think
we need to need to be in the same room
in the vicinity you know with this high
frequency long-range communication of
video chat but we can we will do that
later tomorrow is going to be you and
yourself thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there